merci
[Musique]
certaines personnes viennent en Alaska pour échapper
s'éloigner de quelque chose
Parfois ils viennent ici chercher
quelque chose
parfois ils le trouvent
[Musique]
Je travaille sur cette affaire
ces hommes disparaissent il y a 48 heures
c'est le dernier coucher de soleil  avant la longue
nuit, la théorie est qu'ils sont sortis pour le regarder,
c'était un événement météorologique
ouais, je traite ça comme une affaire de meurtre,
à quel point il faut avoir peur de courir sur
la glace sans chaussures,
hé, c'est une scène de crime,
je veux  pour travailler avec toi, regarde-toi dans
le miroir,
personne ne peut te supporter, tu vas juste
faire cette seule chose, travailler ensemble pour clôturer l'
affaire Miss, c'est tout
pour nous deux, oui, c'est vrai,
tu ne penses pas vraiment que nous allons le faire.  trouvez-
les, assurez-vous qu'ils veulent
croire à certains miracles,
nous n'avons rien, nous n'avons rien, c'est
sûr que vous êtes prêt pour ça,
ce troisième jour sombre et ça
devient déjà bizarre.
[Musique] je
n'ai tout simplement pas de questions  répond
le pays de la nuit, il nous emmène un par un,
c'est fou de me tirer dessus pour survivre